tell you this by the way this is just
the truths of life yeah a lot of people
don't think about when you're 20 child
and yet you get them [__]
I should have minded my business that's
why they got flocking that day there you
go
you [__] that pig and the next day you
erasing that's why
[Music]
brown sugar what's up you bad
[__] your uncle Joey here
coming into your living room
hopefully Obama ended his beautiful
[__] speech and now it's time for
uncle Joey's [__] speech I'm here my
main man Lisa at the King of the Jews
and uncle Joey welcoming you you know
I'm saying cuz I know you're sitting
there going Joey it's Tuesday night what
am I gonna do do I shoot myself do I
wait for the [__] show on [__]
Comedy Central with the Nerdist and the
three people no no we're just talking
about shooting yourself at home and [__]
I'm lucky I'm here with you [__]
tonight we are we've we got edibles a
debt and most importantly we got our
hearts our souls and our minds concept
and that's all that matters at the end
of the day we got some [__]
tremendous weed it's been rainy here Sam
been able to try out my weed I got some
weed in the car this is the [__] Carrie
Fisher smoked when she died
this is the [__] she smoked when she saw
Star Wars and a head blew up
[Music]
brown sugar who the [__] you think you
deal with baby this is straight out the
lung field if you're 18 hang up right
[__] now I got no time for this [__]
you understand me look what we got
tonight bound not one moon Bob with to
me and leading the ball and a half
tonight we're taking into the murky war
there's no more [__] nickel and
diming enter oh my god just opening the
stuff you could smell the [__] p8
Seas and the [__] gorilla biscuit
juice they put in hit you bad
[__] you that's when you wanna
see a devil not to hang out with stupid
white people on law this is it right
here
lalu not far he'll take you to places
you've never been
I'm saying there you go he's puking
already whoo it's a beautiful night to
be alive it's Tuesday
the 10th a [__] January
Cleveland
I'm coming [__] strap on a pair you
dirty [__]
Thursday night 8 o'clock show I'd only
hear those stories [__] uncle Joey
direct direct stars I got first direct
flight I got stars coming over there
I got a shipment headed to [__]
Cleveland right now that could choke a
mule I got the one-eyed you wait for me
I got everything I got snowflakes I got
[__] snowstorms
I got snow boots winter jackets
no jokes you bad [__] you I'm
happy you're here with me I missed you
[__] willing a [__] up
tonight pillow shop feed together oh
[__]
this is the one this is the one right
here
don't rocket look at this [__]
rocket fudge you know what this does to
you even your intestines get [__]
high you all [__] for three days but
listen the fiddle-faddle cuz we got
plenty of talk about tonight most
importantly 2017
and how you gonna put it [__]
together and that's it I took the same
problem - I don't know what to do
waiting I'm talking to a [__] phone
screen for because I got options
[Music]
look at that man you want to smoke what
uncle Joey
I don't [__] think so I'll blow that
smoke in your face you're high ball for
[__] tongue right without smoking
understand me with the leaves all happy
over there and [__] he ate his first
chocolate bar you don't know he's
putting out another half a rocket
[__] fudge and a few stars and a few
metal and Kahoot all pills look at this
one here oh my goodness I'm already it's
already hitting my system I can feel
[__] booth box
[Music]
and tremendous weight here tonight
people this from the Russians Oh
call [__] madman fire when you come
out to California
I'll have you out at the Voodoo Lounge
and you'll see what life is all about
[__] if you're under 18 hang up
Mel I don't want no drama with your
parents [__] [__] watch your
kids I'd only say it got to Romy oh yeah
went to jiu-jitsu today went yesterday
then okay today got killed yesterday got
killed last week but that's the [__]
odds you understand me every 10 times I
go I do okay one of the 10 times that's
how bad I am but I keep going why I
don't [__] know I'm losing a little
weight I'm breathing better I'm moving
on my back more I'm saying that's the
reason why I wouldn't have stuck with
you Jitsu if it wasn't for duel comedy
at the 10 year mark economy I was still
getting the eggs thrown at me and [__]
but I stuck it out I stuck it out like
[__] Richard Gere in office on the
gentleman cuz I got nowhere else to go
I'm doing the same thing with your Jitsu
the worst thing that could happen is
again shape will make your qualifier
Department nobody blows [__] clouds
like that [__] it's time for Lisa add
he's been sitting there patiently going
joy when do I get a [__] pumpkin why
am i treated with such disrespect
[Music]
it's a beautiful night to get together
you know that people special still on
seesaw podcast is doing great
my daughter's great leaves great my
health is good your health is good who
could be [__] happy I remember what I
yell you got dick when my skin was
turning green years ago and I had no
locks if you look at me now
jumping jacks the whole [__] there
look at this one here oh [__] that's the
mule people I told you this weed is the
mule and the fondant is the [__] got
one more they don't know
that's tremendous reef I've been trying
to tell you people listen guys there's a
thousand weed stores I got two or three
people they give me the best okay I'll
tell you some other time I don't wanna
put no people down here but like this
weed here this comes from a direct
[__] source he only calls when he's
got that I told them already don't call
me with all that either Mickey Mouse
[__] here anything under 25 [__]
percent I can't nothing's gonna happen
to me I needed up there 28 dirty like my
boy up there
they gotta had the we from Vice that's
[__] at rbj forty that [__] they gave
me from [__] the mountains Indian
people delivered it to me that [__] was
tremendous you finish that we don't look
at this [__] three things down they
don't live with a bunch of them they
gotta stand now oh yeah we got this for
a month now now you have to contact them
tomorrow so we're gonna be your main
[__] people here
we're gonna do a little [__] left
over my mic my wife made something today
that loved as a child sloppy joes
Oh fresh with green peppers and red
peppers and onions cut into the meat and
she didn't close the sandwich she left a
bread open and she poured on top with a
salad bar boom I think any cartilages
and those two pieces of [__] Wonder
Bread [__] hamburger
[Music]
and we gonna get that type of love from
the smoke-filled ballroom
you ready for another one [__] yeah I'm
happy you came tonight guys I've been
missing you remember without you guys me
and Lee got Dickel guts so I'm happy you
come oh [__]
dance little sister dance it pays to
smoke the best you understand you gotta
keep your lungs in good shape man okay a
[Music]
podcast night sponsored by Cecil and
blue [__] apron and never
forget the immortal on it they sent me
some more club bars tonight some club
but steel bars I got some ten pounders
now to [__] them you rub out your wrists
until you have exercises you go around
your head and you risk it nice and
[__] loose you put that chemical in
your body and it releases the [__]
that thing to help you coat your joints
tremendously if I'm running a lot of
[__] [__] at my age now it's
interesting I'm still a fat [__] but at
least I'm doing something about it you
understand me it's not like I'm sad I'm
sitting eating cheeseburgers gonna lose
it's gonna go away
Lee's ready to dance little sister dance
oh [__] that's the bond headed that
great family that's the one right there
that's the one that there's the one
Kennedy doing his head blew off like
that it's the one oh [__] smoke signals
you understand me
we're building soldiers here America you
want to build the soldier send them
direct Dunkel Joey we're making [__]
soldiers out of only [__] you like the
colors in the road oh yeah are we ready
for some stars how can there be a party
without stars
I got fun listening so much [__] in this
bag with us we got some transmission
fluid transmission cooler Tuesday
transmission fluid Tuesdays that's a
comparison and they both start with T we
got a party we got loose weed
we got Jimmy Page Jimmy Holloway who
loves you [__]
[Music]
we got joints we got maracas what I'm
gonna do perhaps a little residential
reason handy because this week was good
this was bro my my man Ryan this [__] is
tremendous I'm gonna put it in here like
this see and now this thing is filled
hey when you come out to visit you open
up a little container pull back
who needs uncle Joey you something what
up what the [__] do you think you're
dealing with some [__] look from
across the street
uncle Joey's thinking about your concert
dance dance little sister dance what do
you say one more Bamba douche and we'll
call it a night you bad [__] I
enjoyed my time with you trust me I'd
rather talk to you the most [__]
people out there
these [__] douchebags our guests
canceled is 6:30 coming can you believe
that no [__] class
[Music]
if you're gonna write like that you a
rock dollar flavor listen I love you
[__] we'll see you in 10 15
minutes get ready to rock me uncle Joey
have a good night
and don't forget Cleveland Thursday
Friday Saturday to show sadly two shows
Friday and one show Thursday it's gonna
[__] Rock that's my gold a little
long I like to [__] around I can take
pictures I can do all that [__] you know
I'm saying just fry there's two shows
they're busy and then people hear the
club will go well they gotta go out that
way
people gonna come in there so Thursday's
the night kind of suckers I'll see you
then stay black you know uncle Joey
loves you
[Music]